Meech on lab I get I guess this is just
the morning of [ __ ] up because not
only were we running late then our
stream couldn't get up just drama today
it's just not going our way there's so
much traffic in New York if you live
here you know
sorry for the delay but you know what
it's Friday we're running on Friday time
running on Friday time I really like I
was practicing sneech I'm live I got in
my head and then I stopped for two
minutes and then we start let's practice
both of them is it different - no it's
literally almost each other live I get
is different from today nobody's not
it's all to the tune of we've got the
funk Smith John lab I guess sorry I put
them want to speech s it so it's hard
it's hard this is hard for her and yet
she graduated something like you guys
not yet
fingers crawling or scrub after they see
how I drag them on my story totally how
did your test go yesterday um the first
one was garbage and so hard and the
second one was fine but like whatever as
long as I pass it's all the matters I'm
getting a call from Morocco should I
pick any he's get degrees my friend Oh
totally I know I studied to get a see
some people study to get AIDS I studied
to get C's C's get degrees like my boobs
anyways we have a fun show for you today
because obviously you know we're gonna
deliver the past five stories but also
we have Mitchell Tenpenny coming on he
is a rising rising country music star
I'm a huge fan of his work snitch is
going to see him in concert tonight
opening up for Old Dominion and Madison
Square Garden and it's just good to get
some country bags up in here I need some
country vibes I haven't had a country
vibes in a long time you know kind of
sound like a country vibe right now
maybe you have a good voice you're like
my stinky shoes or I'm like in pitch
perfect I have nodes and I can reach
lower notes now do you want to give it a
shot and really piss off all those
podcasts review no I can't because
Claudia when I co-hosted with her was
like trying to get me to sing so badly
cuz like you know she's like I just like
what is weird like that
cuz she says she never hears my voice
like you know what my voice sounds like
it's not good yeah and so now I can't do
it because I have this stubborn because
your your StubHub however Claudia's
talent might be singing but my talent is
getting people to sing especially cloudy
people get Mitchell's man penning so if
you just give us like a little a little
bit of the climb to see where you're not
yeah I'm sorry I can't you really you're
gonna be a freak like yeah
oh my god she's such a freak but she's a
snitch anyway today's nishan let
baguette its french camper here so you
never know what you're gonna get with
the french hamper she's very dynamic
she's dynamic and the French are an
unpredictable people you know maybe
she's gonna go out for a smoke break in
a few minutes though chain smoke a few
six you just never know maybe no maybe
she's gonna whip out a jewel you should
have brought your jewel imagine if you
guys started just Julie on onset you
know what like as much as I'm not here
for you know the the war against the
jewel I'm also like not trying to want I
think it's against FDA regulations to
smoke on TV and technically this is a TV
show one of the greatest in the land so
I don't wanna get in trouble with the
FDA and to you know I do want to set a
good example for people I'm not gonna
encourage dueling but if you are an
existing jeweler I'm not gonna shame you
yeah that's where I'm at
no I'm not gonna force a jewel down your
throat but no but like if we're doing if
we were to see jewel on the show would
be promoting jewels and you know what
I'm not sure I'm not going down that
route but I'm also not the truth
commercial okay well like I wasn't
asking for like I was just like making a
joke I can match it but no but I'm
saying French camper would do such a
thing
yes maybe I was saying just like today
today I mean I didn't think of it maybe
you and we had a very hard morning but
also I really do think it's illegal to
jewel like on TV to jewel tease people
say that no it's like if that you have a
cigarette for Jules
you can't actually show anyone blowing
smoke TV [ __ ] like it's interesting yeah
the FDA is cracking down snitch
interasante very interest on so it's
Friday and as I noted in the car this is
the last episode of the morning toast
where we will not know who sits on the
Iron Throne like that is staggering
death scary that's crazy that's crazy
so top off Game of Thrones finale week
we're definitely gonna be talking about
Game of Thrones but without further ado
I think it's time to get into the Fast
Five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast I have to manually
make the sound because Jake just stepped
out for a second yeah I'm thinking that
I was like you're rushing into it he
just walked out I love making the sound
when we do podcast episodes I'm I am
personally I'm sure they don't even
notice a difference yes so on point no I
I got it okay so first story an update
in the James Charles
which has really died we haven't spoken
about this week which is shocking I
haven't spoken right now but I spoke
about it with Claude because I mean I
don't want to add to the pile on you
know I feel like everyone on the
Internet has that taken care of
yeah I shared my opinions which was that
you know this drama is whatever but it's
like who his character is the reason why
so many people are happy to see him go
down you know I understand so I mean the
crime that was committed like yeah
definitely like shitty friend like sugar
bear hair whatever then it's the things
that have come out post yeah you know so
it's never just the thing it's never
just the thing
youtuber Tati Westbrook releases a new
video about James Charles quote this was
really a wake up call
makeup artist and youtuber Tati
Westbrook is explaining why she posted
the 43 minute teardown of her former
mentee fellow beauty youtuber and
covergirl ambassador James Charles that
has torn the beauty community apart in a
new video uploaded on Thursday entitled
why I did it
the halo Beauty founder said that she
made the video as an attempt at a wake
up call for Charles this was real halo
Beauty line West books immediate
response was also on Instagram without
naming Charles directly Westbrook said
she felt betrayed and lost okay so since
the videos come out there have been a
lot of different things happening like
first of all there's a lot of straight
men coming out now saying that James
Charles has like tried to turn them
did you see you do J Alvarez yes oh my
god like cuz he like I feel like it
really is not the time to get involved
but all you did was just posed to
screenshot him it's like that's just
telling you no telling and for those of
you who don't know who J Alvarez is you
actually do he is an Instagram model but
he's best known for being the Instagram
model boyfriend of Alexis Wren when they
were polarized coming up together as
like you know Instagram goals boyfriend
and girlfriend so you do know who he and
you remember Jared I'm Savannah yes you
usually want me to be like Jared and
Savannah I said if you played your cards
right you could have been like a part of
a Jared in Savannah
no no because this is during a time when
I actually did have a boyfriend and you
wanted me to be Jared and I know you
played your cards wrong where are they
now though Oh Savannah is like you
thought es person on the planet on
Instagram like it's out of control and I
think that correct me if I'm wrong I
think jared is just like a regular dude
now or maybe he's trying to be a thirsty
male influence maybe she
- Jared maybe he was never that cute uh
I don't remember them all so like they
really were 12 and they really were time
when like I was 20
no they were really were 12 and they
were like kind of like gross like they
were like making out on camera but
you're so young yeah back to J Alvarez
in the James Shaw but Charles of it all
that was just so shocking like I was
like J you know - there was a bunch of
girls who I mean like who was it uh
which pop star Larsson Darla I was like
it's not tulip it's not maybe our sins
are Larsson she's in the same category
of just like up-and-coming pop stars
who's had like James child run after her
boyfriend so there's like that whole
road then there's also like this nikita
dragon thing with these text messages
that nikita posted to sort of absolve
james but they actually in created it
they it made it make even less sense
like when did you contact sugar bear
hair weekend one or weekend - so now is
he is in two minutes but then someone if
you saw a screenshot of his Instagram
that he posted at the same time those
texts were saying he just went and got
his coffee so it's all just getting
worse and worse for him and I thought it
was dying down but now taki Westbrook
has put up another video and I actually
didn't watch this video I started to I
didn't have the patience cuz we were
really sitting in traffic and I was
anxious I watched it what are you as the
expert I watched it like I'm fully teen
Tati obviously but it really just kind
of made me uncomfortable like and it's
like I don't think that the tears were
crocodile tears I think that she
genuinely like feels really like guilty
for how much this is taken on like I
don't think she really ever meant to
destroy James Charles cuz she said she
was like I thought that I was gonna be
the one getting back fire from all these
because he had like such crazy stands
uh-huh
but I what happened after this like I
was shocked she's like I don't really
can't like I don't want the subscribers
like if you guys are just gonna like
abuse and like hate on him like blah
blah blah blah there was really like no
point to the video stuff she just
continued to talk about which I thought
was weird because it's like it was it's
not dying down but it was like kind that
she must just be like sitting at home
like feeling so badly and and weird and
not knowing what to do with these new
subscribers that you just wanted an
outlet to be like I didn't mean for this
cuz I does seem like she definitely did
not mean for all of this yeah
and I think like so much of the time
with the YouTube drama it really stays
within YouTube like I didn't now that
I'm learning about James Charles and all
this I didn't know that he had beef with
jaclyn hill and Jeffrey star and that
all these people fight and then they're
friends and like it's really within the
YouTube community so I think she made
that video to explain herself to the
YouTube committee oh the YouTube
community but now it's like on e news
run on the nightly news and she was
posted on his Instagram she never
thought she said would get to that level
she was just trying to say her piece so
that the drama channel so what was
interesting was she was saying the name
of videos why I did so choose she's
basically reiterating like all the
things that she already said in the
video just that like he was unreachable
like you had to call him out like he
wouldn't like listen to me blah blah
blah so all the same but then she said
something very interesting it was
uploaded on Thursday and she said uh
today is Wednesday and I tried to meet
with James Charles via the YouTube and
Google offices like that was like
they're like I guess a medium of
communication because like maybe he
won't talk to her I don't know but I saw
that was an interesting fact right now
I'm assuming that they didn't meet cuz
she that is like YouTube gets involved
like for fake and the beef yeah steak
and the beef sounds like a delicious
feast at Outback yeah anyways I think it
was all necessary but my thoughts on you
know cancel culture remain the same and
I've now seen like a lot of actually not
a lot because most people you know are
part of the pile on but there are a few
people who are like really worried about
his mental health I'm already about his
men to help for sure um and I think it
speaks like a larger problem in our
society that one that is roaring to a
head here you know with like canceled
culture and and where where does it stop
also did you see the photos of him in
Brisbane Brisbane Airport I did like it
gave me like weird vibes
he was like inhales like ready for I
didn't look upset was like kind of
smirking and like seemed kind of fine
obviously like you can't really tell him
maybe he's putting on a face but like
then I saw this whole post in the
morning tube which is like you gotta get
in that so really it's just especially
with this it's helped me keep so
up-to-date got it that like they're like
starting the James Charles PR like then
their team is starting their whole you
know campaign campaign and like this was
part of it like
they were saying why would the paparazzi
be outside like I was him getting out of
the car like how they knows him getting
out of the car like just all these
things with all paparazzi in Australia
yeah I don't know I actually watching
the interview of Hugh Jackman in
Australia the paparazzi are very lovely
he said he makes a deal with them he's
like you want a picture of me running on
the beach I'll be here at this time then
leave me alone they're like okay so they
seem quite lovely
okay I mean I might be able them to get
into the morning too but I'm not
convinced no I'm not convinced but like
he it was definitely we are like why are
you wearing heels the airport shouldn't
you be like trying to be incognito yeah
I hope he I hope at the very least he
takes away the right lessons from this
which is you know come back down to
earth you're still a human being they're
still 19 years old yeah like you're just
like everyone else you're no better and
no worse and just you know do the right
thing
stop being an [ __ ] that seems to be
the right lesson yeah you know and like
stop being like a predatory yeah it
doesn't work for anyone ever especially
now so yeah this is not the time okay
sweet so we'll continue to update you
but I was not expecting a video from her
about this like I thought she would just
like post a video you know promoting her
hallo beauty with all her new
subscribers and then people were like
doubled that's greater than five to ten
that's crazy but then people would
accuse her of like being thirsty but you
know it thirst it out like you have a
mind John the third these opportunities
don't come all the time she said in the
video she's like that she's taking a
break from YouTube but she has things
that I've already been pre-taped so she
might upload them cool I wonder what was
pre-taped but I feel like when she talks
about her new subscribers these
subscribers it's like I'm a new
subscriber and I'm not there to hate on
James Charles I just thought she was
well-spoken and beautiful and I want to
hear what she has to say really I feel
like so many of her new subscribers are
just people who are being introduced to
her for the first time because she was
on e news agreed but then but after I
watched the video a video that she's
posted of her reviewing the k'kaw Beauty
contour
stuff started and like wasn't nearly as
good like the am comfortable yeah really
yeah like watching her vlog with like
made me feel weird I don't know okay but
do you typically let other than Olivia
Jade you like Beauty youtubers oh I love
the beauty chores I took live my days
well I'm a teen woman she's not Beauty I
guess but she does she works at all day
so I don't know oh and I wonder your
favorite yeah have I ever went rare I
know I post once every six months meat
ever watched one
yeah I didn't want to preset one just
because I know how but I'm very sure are
you loving my presets I am loving your
presets it's really brightening up my
flow and just in time it's for sharing I
couldn't I couldn't agree more you time
do release so perfectly I mean you know
it's a it was a happy accident uh
but I'm loving the Jackie O flow a
hashtag just keeps poppin on every day
like I'm so impressed also it's really
so great for dog accounts I'm realizing
like there's so many dogs on the Jackie
O flow and the picture I posted last
night like you should have seen the
original it was like so weird what was i
right
oh no it wasn't so I posted a picture
from my outfit last night was wearing
like all pink eye
I looked cute but a little insane and
the the preset was premium but it wasn't
think pink it was actually cha-cha
because I needed the Blues of the
background to come out I understand and
my out who is already so pink it didn't
need to be more pink right anyway it's
just an interesting factoid that's well
interesting okay next story we have some
ABC drama because Kelly Ripa is
exasperated by Bachelorette Twitter
tirade okay earlier this week Kelly Ripa
made a comment about how like the show
disgusts her whatever Kelly Ripa feels
exasperated by The Bachelor morons
following their Twitter tirade at her
morons is her word Ripa who has never
made it any secret she hates The
Bachelor series was stunned when both
host Chris Harrison and show creator
Mike Fleiss launched an attack at her
online she shared her thoughts about the
ABC reality franchise on her daytime
talk show live with Kelly and Ryan
telling the audience on Tuesday quote
you guys know how I feel about the show
it disgusts me I can't stand the idea of
25 exceptional women fighting over one
ordinary fella in my opinion you know
how I feel ladies we are too special to
be arguing over a guy it wasn't long
before Harrison and Fleiss took to
social media to gripe quote look out
bachelor nation at Kelly Ripa is coming
after you and your quote disgusting
Monday night habit Harrison tweeted
while Fleiss wrote easy Kelly Ripa The
Bachelor franchise pays your salary
however a source close to the star told
Paige sex how dumb can you get Kelly
salary is paid by ABC syndication and
The Bachelor brand is produced by ABC
Entertainment there are two separate
entities they have nothing to do with
each other and why make this so personal
Kelly's said way worse about the
bachelor and pass the joke is that this
is the least offensive
she's ever done this just seems
desperate okay here's my thoughts on
this I'm team Kelly here because you
know what like for The Bachelor doesn't
disgust me by any means but I feel like
just because she's part of ABC doesn't
mean that she's has just like yes
technically you know she should be like
a corporate team player don't bite the
hand that feeds you but I feel like it
makes her audience trust her more yes
she can like find fault in an ABC
programming like I think it was just a
really honest and like human thing to do
um obviously you know it's not great for
business but it's not gonna affect ABC's
ratings and it shows that you know just
because we're an ABC show doesn't mean
that we're gonna be dishonest I thought
it was kind of cool yeah I mean like I'm
not Team Bachelor team Kelly I'm more
team Hannah like she went on live with
Kelly and Ryan yesterday and like she
confronted the beast beast beast and she
was just like so normal I'm well-spoken
shockingly and she was just like it's
really like not like that like I she's
like we're not all fighting over the
same man it's more so like I met my best
friends for the show like obviously if
you put 30 girls in the house like not
everyone's gonna like each other but
like that's really not like what the
vibe was about so I think that also it's
like the bat there's the bachelor
there's let's not forget there's the
bachelor but there's also the
Bachelorette the security guys fighting
over one girl right I want to know her
thoughts on the baths tried it said
because that's what's happening right
now so I thought that was sort of like
you know it was like MIT misguided
timing a little bit because like it is
the Bachelorette season so does it still
disgust you but then also I expect from
my kleiss to come in their bachelor pays
her salary etc but I thought Chris
Harrison doing it was like low and I
expect more from him like he's always
you know on the brink of drama you know
he's right there and he always takes the
high road so as America's like host and
you know referee I didn't like this side
of him I agree I was shocked that he
even said something I feel like he never
speaks yeah but for me like I mean I
know Kelly Ripa like on her show she's
like so fun and positive and she's just
like the Energizer Bunny and then like
behind the scenes I think she's a little
bit of a diva but for me like this I
thought it showed that like she has like
a big set of balls she does have a
ginormous set of balls I respect that I
mean to
but like I I also am very much of the
mentality like do not bite the hand that
feeds you yeah but I don't think ABC
doesn't care they're talking about the
bathroom bathroom and my became you know
what like Jimmy Kimmel whenever he has
the contestants on he's also part of ABC
and he makes so much fun of them and so
much fun of the show and and why is that
acceptable like he put like he literally
is poking holes in the show all of the
time saying that these couples won't
make it and if you do I'll pay you a
thousand dollars no one ever makes it
from the show like why is that okay
right and Kelly Rebeck just can't like
voice a harmless by the way not in
correct opinion know about The Bachelor
and that an opinion that a lot of other
people hold it is controversial in this
day and age like like shock that it's a
leavin goes on it's true so I'm I'm team
Kelly on this one just cuz I like a big
set of balls I like a big set of balls
and you know and Mike Fleiss is still in
or a [ __ ] basket and she's the devil
anyone who wants to go at it with my
place as a hero in my book agreed agreed
speaking of maybe seed you know that
they have a new show coming out this
summer that looks so good it's called
Grand Hotel it's ABC sexy summer drama
and it's gonna be your new guilty
pleasure a five-star hotel with
five-star secrets set along the gorgeous
backdrop of Miami Beach this sounds lit
and more than that Eva Longoria
executive produces this bold and
provocative family drama drenched in
romance and mystery literally sounds
like the show that I've been waiting for
a young woman's disappearance during a
hurricane unravels slew of scandals and
lies it's like clue for television
sounds like Pretty Little Liars
it sounds so freakin good it's a
contemporary fresh take on an upstairs
Downstairs story as the staffs lives
intertwine with the owners of the hotel
and nobody is who they seem Wow I will
be tuning in check out Grand Hotel on
Monday June 17th on ABC so it'll be
right after the Bachelorette on Mondays
premiering on June 17 and I'm actually
so excited
I love Eva Longoria and I want to
support everything that she does too but
more than the bike even more this just
sounds so good and I I need a new sexy
summer drop I need a new sexy summer
drop like it's time I agree speaking of
new shows southern charm premiered this
week it didn't get a chance to recap it
but it's in the news because southern
charm producers want to be done with
Thomas Ravenel zhn Annie's sexual
assault lawsuit okay so
then charm premiered and I love this
show I think it's actually one of the
greatest shows on TV and it really goes
like head to head with and remember
rules and right now like it's southern
charm my issue with the first episode
was that like so much stuff has happened
between them beginning them ending
filming and beginning filming and I
almost was someone like ham and just sat
down and story time that for us because
they keep going back and forth and it
was just like an episode of recap right
where and they it was confusing you know
so anyway southern term producers and
Bravo are asking a judge to let them be
free of the lawsuit that Thomas Ravenel
is former nanny brought against them the
producers in the network filed court
documents asking to be released from the
case saying to releases that John
ledwell signed to appear on the show
according to court documents obtained by
the blast the outlet port of the Chi
Minh signed one release after she was
allegedly assaulted by right now the
producers and Bravo also said in their
court documents that the releases state
that any issues would be heard in
arbitration in New York not in South
Carolina where lead well and Ravenel
reside they want the case dismissed on
that basis so yeah they're in a tough
position because one of their I don't
know if you watch the other time but you
should one of their main cast members
has now been accused of sexual assault
rape he's no I know about I know about
Thomas obviously and so they have to
address it on the show but it really is
like a big stain for the whole show but
yeah yeah is he still on the show no
he's off of the show so they must
address it but it's clear that no one
wants to because also it is an ongoing
court case whatever they say on the show
they could be subpoenaed to testify and
like it's just a hot mess yeah so it's
it's not ideal i but they need to keep
talking about it because it's what
happened and they can't just sweep it
under the rug cuz that's why how and why
these things keep happening right so
they're in a tough spot
i thought they'd help handled it really
well in the first episode but we'll see
if they keep talking about it throughout
the season right but they have to well
but he has two kids with one of the
customers Catherine Catherine I love her
justice for Catherine is being served in
leaps and bounds this season and I am
loving it truly she was on watch what
happens live with Patricia which is just
like something is traditionally one of
the skinny confidential she went to her
house
when those stories were amazing yes she
is now that she's cool Catherine I'm
cool with her but for a long she was
just like pure evil she's just like so
condescending and mean so I don't know I
don't know man but it's looking like a
good season everyone has something
interesting going on there's any homie
still on it
yeah I love her love her she has a new
man and she's like [ __ ] on it yeah and
they like workout together and she's so
happy and they're so cute that's right
I'm happy for her and now I think in
real life Craig has a girlfriend I think
I saw that so it's all good oh good I
love it I really love everyone on the
show there's no one that I don't like
because it was Ashley and she was gone
but apparently she comes back this
season anyways this season looks wet I
can't wait for it next story a weird a
headline you you don't expect to read
everything okay
Jersey Shore star Ronnie ortiz-magro
reveals he got liposuction Ronnie
ortiz-magro went under the knife to help
get his six-pack back the Jersey Shore
family vacation star revealed in an
upcoming episode of the doctors that he
decided to get liposuction because he
didn't have time to work out after his
daughter's birth I've always been a
workout fanatic and I've always been in
shape but it takes a lot of hard work to
stay in shape the 33 year old said in
the clip obtained by people one year ago
today my life completely changed I had a
little baby girl she's like my guardian
angel and now I can't spend 2 to 3 hours
every day in the gym gym like I used to
Ortiz magros plastic surgeon dr.
Christopher course and share that he was
doing a laser high definition
liposuction of the abdomen which wasn't
even available ten years ago okay um I
don't know how I feel about liposuction
and I mean in general it's just like do
what you want to do do what makes you
happy and on the one hand I feel like
liposuction is like the answer to all my
problems oh then on the other hand I
feel like it's you know the premise for
so many episodes of botched yeah so I'm
on the fence about the procedure I'm on
the fence about the procedure too and
it's like I feel like he's like all
muscle like there's nothing really -
yeah I know so and I feel like okay so
you let yourself go a little bit after
your baby like that's okay women go
through that all the time like yeah you
don't it's a lot of he must be under so
much pressure to be like GTL you know
but I feel like like no one would really
care I mean do what you got to do but
like it seems like a little extreme a
little extreme you know he just had to
be
like give yourself some time yeah and
also like I feel like he loves going to
the gym like just like work on it
yourself I don't know I'm not here to
criticize someone for their choices but
it seems a little weird yeah it was just
it was unexpected when I heard it
it's Jersey Shore family vacations still
on like I have no idea I obviously
stopped watching it kind of lost
interest but I heard it's good yeah I
stopped watching because I don't no
longer have MTV with my provider with my
cable provider because you don't have a
cable provider no but I have my spectrum
logins so it's not on spectrum anymore
MTV's not on spectrum anymore mmm
positive no I'm sorry DIRECTV oh oh that
makes sense
yes like I know I have I have a TV in a
while but I'm pretty sure it's still
there
no I have DirecTV cable logins and I'm
TVs not under it okay that makes sense
I'm speaking of MTV I want to talk about
Juliette Porter and Robbie he's dating
me too because I don't know my thoughts
on it I'm happy she's not back together
with Alex that is for sure but I don't
know if Robbie is better or worse I
don't know if he actually has good
intentions I don't know maybe it's a PR
relationship for he's coming on Siesta
Key
I really don't know all I know is that
the pota photo she posted with him she
looked [ __ ] bangin and that's all I
care it was a great photo I all I care
about for her is like really her
happiness right um if it is a real
relationship I don't even know what my
problem with Robbie he's is like or me
neither you know cuz he's only ever been
nothing but like nice but I just feel
like as a boyfriend like he's not really
boyfriend material like he's a little
bit look like [ __ ] boy you know he's
like enjoys being famous and you know
all of that he's been on Vanderpump
rules now now he's a lon Vanderpump yes
because he went on a date with Sheena Oh
God and now he's gonna be on Siesta Key
and like that's just it seems just like
you're a reality show hopper right but
you know I I look forward to the day
that Juliet shows up you know at the at
the Crab Shack Oh Robbie hey Foreman
ciao Alex's birthday party this summer
right cuz you know ever it has to go
right Robbie haze like that's what I'm
hearing for I'm happy that we're not
getting another season I'll be like Oh
right crying no I'm so here for her
being with like I have a new man on my
arm you can go [ __ ] yourself
bye I wish out to get off the goddamn
show but we can't because his dad like
me it yeah it's so it's so difficult I'm
not caught up though like I I think I
have like the last four episodes to
watch which I I think are like the good
one so I'm gonna have to watch it it's
all good it's enjoyable I need to like
watch it on a rainy day so like not till
the fall because summer is here yes okay
summer might be here but winter is here
and get over 200,000 Game of Thrones
fans have signed a petition calling for
the final season redo by competent
writers this is just like so hilarious
thousands of Game of Thrones fans are
voicing their discontent with the eighth
and final season of the wildly popular
award-winning HBO drama and are calling
out the show's writing staff in the
process the change.org petition has
surfaced wait I want to see how many
signatures it's up to now holy [ __ ] it's
up to eight hundred and twenty five
thousand signatures it's almost a
million the petition is surfaced urging
the premium cable network to remake Game
of Thrones season eight with competent
writers and as of Wednesday evening the
petition officially met its 200,000
signature goal oh my god that's only two
days ago after being created just last
week quote David Benioff and DB Weiss
have proven themselves to be woefully
incompetent writers when they have no
source material ie the books to fall
back on the petitions creator said on
the site referring to the dramas show
runners this series deserves a final
season that makes sense subvert my
expectations and make it happen HBO oh
my god I mean I'm not gonna be that
[ __ ] that signs that cuz that's just
horrible these people have worked so
hard but like I can't lie like they they
might have a point like the writing is
not good and the writing has got gotten
worse and worse since the books since
they stopped relying on the books well
okay we don't really know how good these
writers are because they had such they
had it written for them yeah I I thought
that george RR martin though he hasn't
finished last two books was involved in
the last two season no I watched it he's
gonna melt it off he might be like if I
have a question but like he is not
writing the he's not writing the script
how could he just let it get away from
him like that
because maybe there's some legal thing I
don't know but he told them how he sees
it
but they were free to do what they
wanted with it which seems weird but he
still has his narrative with his books
and a lot of people still we read the
book and they read the books a lot of
people are like now going to read the
final books just because they want in a
different not even ending just a
different like plot but I still think
even if it we were back at season six
like we always knew that Daenerys we
hope we wanted her to take the throne
but we also always knew that you know
it's never gonna be that happy ending
that we want and once we knew that John
was actually the rightful heir I think
we all kind of knew that Daenerys
wouldn't make it to the throne like I I
never wanted to I don't think people are
upset that Danny's Arkham taken okay
they're upset that like she went mad at
and they don't think it makes sense but
like that's the creator's way of getting
her off the throne maybe george RR
martin has a different way but i think
at the end of the day no matter who's
writing it she's not sitting there not
upset i don't think they're upset about
like these big things that are happening
it's more so that like they'll lead up
to it like make it make sense to get
there it doesn't be doesn't make sense
to me we shouldn't have to try so hard
to try and make it to make sense it's
what I think I'm not even trying like I
understand why this [ __ ] lost her mind
I understand my speech Oster mind but
she's always tried to do the right thing
like that's been her thing freeing slate
no because people yes she's always
wanted to free slaves or whatever but go
about it in the wrong way but she's
never she's always had advisors to see
her if you really watch the season she
already has this consciousness to
violence at every turn until Jorah or
someone tells her to do something
different and she listens but she has
not one advisor I mean you can't say
that you thought the season was gonna be
better that you didn't think the season
was gonna be better I'm enjoying it the
only thing that it sucks is everyone
complaining every time i watch episode I
enjoy it even when nothing happens and
then you and Claudia are like and it's
fun I liked it I liked it I enjoy
watching the show because it's a new
episode of the show but it's like when
you have created these standards for
yourself and then you completely kind of
botch them like people are gonna be
upset I don't think they've been bad but
you know that the writers like are not
checking like they probably don't even
know about this like they they are
literally in a in a house deep in some
foreign country with their wives and
their only
gonna come out after it's all over and
they're gonna ask their PR person from
Ichi I would be like how bad was it
there was a whole interview about it oh
wow I I hope the PR person speaks to me
because you know what I'm enjoying it I
think I'm just gonna look at Twitter no
Twitter is the worst place to go or else
you think everyone's team James but
there apparently we did pull dirty James
people are oh everyone is our assignment
team Charles we spoke about this people
our team everyone else in the toasters
but Len like everyone feels like James
is really being like gaslighted and
bullied and I felt like he was moreso
being bullied this season but not during
the reunion and then they were like what
what can James do is he said if he's
nice they say he's being insincere and
if he's mean they say he's being a bully
but it's like why doesn't James just do
what he thinks is right in his soul and
stick to it if he's nice and six to that
eventually it will pay off but if that's
really like what he genuinely feels he
shouldn't just choose one or the other
based on what's gonna have him be
accepted like what does he think is the
right thing to do does he really want to
be an [ __ ] to see really hate these
people then do that and stop with your
[ __ ] apologies like I that's such
[ __ ] to me like it's damned if he
does he's damned if he doesn't well why
does he just do what he thinks is right
in this hole and stick with it and stop
just trying to like be a I don't know
liked or hated like you want to be liked
or hated and then what do you think is
best for you maybe he should talk to me
anyways snitch well before we bring out
Mitchell Tenpenny I just wanna you know
wrap up this week of snitch on the toes
yeah because you have a big week coming
up next week and we're also excited for
you here at the toast community at toast
HQ because this is really a new chapter
for you yeah so how are you feeling like
this is last time we're gonna see you
before you're a college grad I know I'm
super excited as pending that I finished
my freakin work this weekend which is
very hard to do I just can't do it but
I'm very excited she's just like never
have to walk back on NYU campus again
like that to me it's just so exciting
like I can't even begin to tell you I'm
excited for this new chapter I'm moving
in with one of my best friends in down
in like you know Murray Hill and so I'm
very excited for that what I'm doing
workwise
will say TBD TBD no I'm just excited to
see you know where this chapter takes me
I feel like everything's gonna change I
don't know why I'm so
excited to see where this chapter takes
you and I mean you know that we love to
ask you about your dating life of course
and I just want to make a suggestion
because the new OkCupid app is out and
OkCupid is the only dating app that
finds you someone based on who you are
and what you're into when it comes to
dating you know exactly what you like
this is true you are StubHub you know
what you like you're and you know what
you don't like the OkCupid dating app
has tons of fun questions about the
things you care about and it's your own
answers that lead to fascinating
conversations and even better dates
isn't that exciting because it's
exciting so see I'll get on it it's so
simple match with someone on what really
matters to you based on the answers to
your questions OkCupid roommate
recommends you to people you can
uniquely connect with people who see the
world like you do so download the free
OkCupid dating app to day I mean this is
her everyone who's just out there
looking for love but also to my sister
because I'm always looking for love for
you you'll make maybe I should make a
profile and catfish people it's not
catfishing if it's I'm just doing it
like somebody a half and then if you
just agree that like you'll go on a date
that I set up it's not a cap do that
it's a little fun but I think we're so
similar that like no it wouldn't be
getting a totally different person a
personality wise when they meet you
right no not at all okay so oh okay keep
it dating app they just like have all
your preference is knowing what you like
and don't like and they're gonna set you
up and and make a match for you like a
nice [ __ ] off and there's nothing better
than that nothing better than a nice
[ __ ] off totally
well that's further ado we are gonna
take a quick break and bring out
Mitchell Tenpenny aka Mitchell Tenpenny
and we will see you shortly
you
welcome back to the morning toast we are
here with Mitchell Tenpenny welcome to
the show thanks for having this is
awesome we are so excited to have you
here we met you at stagecoach so where
we go way back girlfriend
how was performing at stagecoach we're
obsessed with the stagecoach festival
that was your first time performing
that's my first time you know I've seen
it in pictures all my friends have been
but there's nothing like getting there
cuz it's all country music fans it's
like from all over the place so they
love the music and it was just I'm gonna
it was a blast
it's Angela yeah and now you're in New
York because you're performing tonight
at Madison Square Garden with opening
for Old Dominion's yeah that is just
center eyed I know yeah another pinch me
moment it's just crazy plus I love that
band so anytime were in New York it's
insane but getting to play there and
then getting to play with Old Dominion
it's just like I don't know what's
happening so no totally I think you know
we're like the we're out here being like
country music evangelist and you're holy
and so it is so hard so snitches coming
to your show tonight I'm very excited we
are huge fans of drunk me like I'll call
you later
I'm inches like oh no totally I was
getting ready to all your music this
morning and I was just like thoroughly
enjoyed myself so drunk me is just like
taken over yeah country radio yeah I
mean this whole last year has just been
crazy from you know releasing our first
single to to now I mean thank God it's
been amazing and it's let us do things
like this I get to come to New York City
get to hang out with y'all so it's been
a it's been a blessing but yeah it's
just a crazy ride and it's also gotten
you as the bartender i watch what
happened side for the southern charm
premiere episode with patricia and
catherine we were just talking about
them on watch what happens live and I
saw you and I was like how was that are
you a Bravo fan I watched some stuff on
Bravo I'll be honest I don't I don't
watch a lot of the the reality shows but
I've definitely seen them before so
anytime like like in music we see a
bunch of artists and stuff and to us
it's like okay we see you every day but
to see actors and people we see on TV or
social media it's different so I like
recognizing them was kind of cool for me
because we just don't get that in
Nashville we don't get a lot of actors
or TV stars or anything like that so it
was cool recognizing them and then I
just got to drink behind the bar and
hang out
sounds pretty cool that is so fun and so
cool like Claudia bartender one time
watch out oh yeah it's just like a
career-high yes yes totally do you ever
watch the show Nashville I did back in
the day like first couple seasons when I
was on ABC yeah and I mean it was
awesome but it was just like we don't
have paparazzi like that naturally your
show getting out of cars and like like
bombarding them with cameras I was like
that's not how it is at all but uh it
was cool I liked it it was kind of
shining light but it also like they
brought a lot of people to national and
so there's a lot more traffic now
Nashville like it's a place to be you
know so much contraction its population
yeah it's blown up it's crazy and
especially being born and raised there
where no one ever cared about Nashville
it's just nuts to see how big it is no
no totally and like really country music
has really like crossing over into the
mainstream and there are so many artists
who are doing that like has that is that
so exciting for you as a rising country
music artist well of course and I mean I
don't ten I mean I'm country music died
you know from from the walk the way I
was raised born and raised in country
music but this day and time it allows us
to kind of experiment with new sounds
and new the way we express ourself in
country music genres so it's it's open
to interpretation at this point that's
what I love it's allowing people like me
to do the music that I want to make and
still be able to hold true to my country
values and that's what I love about
country music today who are your
favorite country artists yes Darryl I
mean Brooks & Dunn growing up as some of
my favorite and Trisha Yearwood
I mean her and Garth like I don't know
back in the day I used to my mom and the
car would just blare that and that's
kinda what I was just you know it was
just always in my ears at all times yeah
honestly the Brooks & Dunn reboot was
something I never knew that I needed and
it's introducing like so I mean someone
like me like to all their old catalogue
right brilliant which I think everyone
should know Brooks had known I mean I'm
biased towards it but it's perfectly did
exactly what you just said it's letting
people who might not have heard that
music and get a chance to hear it
because it's great and you need to know
percent dog for sure totally
and so who are some of like the
contemporary artists that are like just
doing cool things in the country music
world for us like we'd love Kacey
Musgraves oh cool she's really like just
straddling
genres I love it actually we just
listened to one of my good friends anger
dangerous she's just coming out and
she's I'm such a huge fan of her we've
been riding for like six years together
and now is her she just got her deal
she's just coming out and launching and
her music is great her writing and she
kind of tends on that indie country yeah
kind of wave to and it's really good
music you should check it out ooh
definitely we always love a new
suggestion yeah who are someone for like
your dream collaborations oh man
John Mayer would be my answer great yes
there's someone like I'm a big fan of
Katy Perry - so something like in that
range but Jon Jon's uh you know I'm a
huge know I got to I walk by him one
time at his concert my buddies open for
him and like I was I freaked out I was
gonna say hey but I just it was like
he's so cool that like yeah I just still
know I want to pick his brain but they
be too smart and witty he's so smart
he's always on watch what happens you
have to get depending on episode that
he's on tired
I wish yeah that would be that would be
amazing yeah I know him and Andy are
good buddies I've seen like tons of hits
ago so I was hoping maybe he would be
there but he wasn't so no totally and
like not to make we're like such a Bravo
heavy show so like the crossover between
watch out in Simon country music was
just like for you and it's not something
you see all the time like Marin Morris
was on as a guest a few weeks ago and
like that was so exciting so how did
that come about
you know cuz you're really like the one
of the few country music artists I've
seen on the show yeah we just got a
phone call management team told me and I
was like yeah of course I mean I know
Andy of course and like but it kind of
blew me away cuz I was like I didn't
think that that was possible for like a
country or just even get a chance to go
on that shows yeah I was just one of
those like cool moments again that those
phone calls you you get what you're like
alright this is pretty this is pretty
well I hope they do more of that cuz
like I that's such a great crossover a
hundred percent next you just gotta
perform they got their little Clubhouse
they should have performances yeah you
should do sometimes they do sometimes
like the housewives themselves perform
right but it's not another level of
performance
when we were at stagecoach you told us
something I've drunk me because there's
that part in the song where you like
kind of just like go off and let go nuts
when you're like we're just like [ __ ]
around in the studio when it happened so
what was that like and it always reminds
me of Bohemian Rhapsody when they're
doing the Galileo's and they break down
the studio everyone's singing it back
yeah oh yeah yeah I mean that's all it
was we were just having fun and I
produced these records with my best
friend Jordan Schmidt who writes who
wrote that song with me and you know we
just when we get in the vocal booth like
well we'll get all the vocals done and
I'll say dude let me run it through into
an ad-lib track and I was just messing
around with him I just like singing back
doing all these runs and stuff and
afterwards I was just laughing I walked
out of birth and laughing I was like
yeah what do you think of that just
Chuck he's like we're keeping I was like
no we're not he's like no we're keeping
that I was like I was completely [ __ ]
with you literally the best part of the
song is a masterpiece with that part
when they come along it's like I just
felt it but now you have to do it every
time I perform yeah and that's the thing
at the end of the song I have to hit
that note every single time now and but
I love it's becoming it it's like those
little moments where they become things
and it's kind of cool but yeah it was
all a complete joke so we have to ask
cuz the toasters are asking are you
single
I'm not single that's exciting how'd you
meet at a bar oh yes you walked in
wearing camo and I was just kind of
intrigued but you were able to see her
yeah a little over here good so like
does she go on tour with you to check
the tour life she's actually an artist
herself she's uh she's Canadian she's up
with Canada Warner Canada but she's
moved Nashville full-time and starting
her career here so which is it's a whole
different transition going from Canada
to the United States it's like basically
starting over and so she's doing
everything and working hard and trying
to you know pursue this dream in the
United States doing country music also
her yes she's a country
sounds like an episode of Nashville
waiting to have yeah like or just like
the reality TV version of Nashville
which yeah yeah I mean it's real I mean
there were a lot of things about that TV
show that are real but there are a lot
of things I love that Stella like oh
yeah there's so much talent well they're
they're incredible and like is see them
live - you could tell that like they're
just there they're singing their
harmonies are amazing yeah and now
they've just kind of blossomed into
their own thing which is rosy which is
awesome but and they started on YouTube
so you know and it haven't here on the
Internet I know I feel like they they I
don't think that they were posting that
many videos on YouTube I think they do
disclose to that one chopped video and
it just completely - yeah yeah yeah it
was just like they really struck gold
yeah my friend Evan Dawson who's now an
artist yes I remember he did a Taylor
Swift cover and and it kind of accepts
you to the next level like it just blew
up on YouTube and then he we ended up
writing a song or playing a song writers
around and Nashville to get them came
best friends and then kind of came up
together it's crazy what the power of
the Internet can do yeah especially at
the very beginning you're looking at it
anyways thank you so much for joining us
so good philosophy at your show tonight
where it's like so excited I was
checking on but I have an engagement -
but yeah well congratulations on
everything thanks for having me you ever
go this will you ever back on much
happens I've we need and ease you over
your house size of Nashville okay so
just like put it happen to me ya know
like that sounds like just the logical
next yeah that would make sense
logically yes logically it's done
anyways everything thank you for joining
us welcome to New York how long you here
for
we leave tonight
of course I love New York City when
shopping yesterday no any clothes I'm
not tell me what she'll tell you where
to go no I think it's the club's like
kind of sucking out nowadays it's more
so just about like yeah that's more
about really a club guy I mean I'm down
to do it but if you know any grey bars
or a good place to D because there's so
places here like we just walked
yesterday and just found a random spot
and ate there like I don't know what's
good and what's so that works too
because I feel like all the food is good
where'd you go shopping I'm a sneaker
guy so I went to like a flight club and
then I always go to Zara when we're in
town or like stuff like that because we
don't have that in Nashville
there's no Zara national it's it's wow
they're missing out yeah I love that
place it's great for me so yeah oh well
my husband's a big sneaker head too so I
have all suggestions yeah yeah there's
any other place besides that I would
love to know
have you been to kiss kiss how you smell
it okay i th you gotta check it out and
they have ice cream - I think my manager
- you made me go to ice cream right
after that okay wonderful well thank you
so much to everyone have a great weekend
we'll be back on Monday and whenever we
go the Game of Thrones finale watching
Thrones
okay I have just started it okay but
I've watched the last three episodes of
the final season so like I already know
it's gonna help my girls watch them all
so I'll watch them and then I watch them
with my buddies just watch it
so I don't know I mean I mean it doesn't
matter I don't care I saw his Instagram
like he's like dead no and like they
were there have been a few celebrity
cameos this season like Aaron Rodgers
was on this episode it sure and was on
last season and he had some speak I say
saying yeah so he was kind of like a
character but I feel like if you had
gotten into Game of Thrones out there
earlier like you could totally have been
like it actually
you're giving me like such a bad guy yes
totally
yeah Ben Stark oh my god yeah no that's
so crazy that we've all that on Monday
so we will see you guys then have a
wonderful weekend and thank you Mitchell
and we look forward to seeing everything
that you do and you know new music let
us know like when we can expect you
thank you guys for having me thank you
bye
you